let me ask you the ridiculous question
since you went from being broke to being
uh Rich although you keep
uh spending all your money but
does money buy happiness how has money
changed sort of your
contentment your happiness in life it's
money by happiness
um
no not I mean to a point yes once you
can take care of your health you can
take care of like any immediate dangers
and you can take care of your family
relatively no it doesn't like but those
things do like when I first came into
money one of the first things I did was
retire my mom and like that brought me
tons of happiness you know what I mean
and like you know if my brother had a
medical emergency and and we couldn't
afford it and I made money to afford it
that would bring tons of happiness you
know so once you take care of those
basic necessities so we'll say makeover
hypothetically a million dollars no it
it really doesn't like adding an extra
zero going from 10 million to 100
million or whatever it is makes no
difference
so you're given that or just fearless
and spending the money yeah well let me
reframe I guess it could for some people
if if you really
I don't know you spent your whole life
obsessing over cars it probably would
bring you a little bit of joy to buy a
nice Lamborghini I I'm coming more from
the frame of mind of of an entrepreneur
someone who's really obsessed with
business ability for me and a lot of my
friends and people I hang around what
brings us happiness is winning and
building companies and do you know
changing the world like that that is fun
it's a complex problem you can wake up
every day and it gives you something to
obsess over and devote your life to
where it's just having money doesn't you
know well one interesting question for
you psychologically so because you
have become wealthy and because you give
like part of your work is giving away a
lot of money
um do you find it hard to find people
you can trust
it's a question do people see you
basically as a source of money as
opposed to another human being it's
weird because you would think yes but I
I feel like I also know the right places
to look
um but yeah if I just walked into Target
and try to make friends with 10 random
people of course
um you gotta
uh so you can kind of sense oh yeah
that's the right thing so quickly right
though yeah that's yeah it's so obvious
so I don't even want to go into
descriptions but
honestly a lot of my friends or like uh
Chandler I I played literally with him
um and Tyler the guy I mean I went to
school with him Chris he was my first
subscriber
um Carl was here after we got big but
whatever he's friends with the boys and
it is a lot of my closer friends even
like my YouTube friends I I knew before
I was big so
maybe there is some mirror to that maybe
it is I I don't know I've never really
put too much thought into it maybe
there's a reason I hang around a lot of
these people I knew before I got paid
because it's much easier and they help
you keep like uh your radar sharp of who
can and can't be trusted because you
know you can trust them yeah it's
difficult when you become richer and
richer and more powerful well one day
one time when you get rich oh yeah not
even richer but more fan one thing I
thought is as I climbed this like ladder
of YouTube and got bigger I thought
there would be tons of people like me
people
how to like that takes like the Kamikaze
approach to building a business you just
throw all your money in it you throw all
your time you throw all your energy
throw everything yeah you're just like
[ __ ] it this is this I'm dead yeah I
thought there would be hundreds of these
yeah and and there isn't there is I mean
there's like maybe one or two and I
talked to those [ __ ] every
single day I'm sick and tired of talking
to them but I love them
um but it's just so interesting because
like every level I got up like I get a
million subscribers like all right
where's all these guys in the million
subscribers that are [ __ ] Psychopaths
and then you know you know there are
people become like conservative as they
get like they get more especially as
they get bigger yeah and you know 20
million subscribers 30. it's like every
step of the way it's like I just got
more and more lonely to be honest since
you you know it sounds cliche and you
hear that kind of [ __ ] in movies and
you're like oh that's not how it works
but it is like there's there's just not
many people that just want to give up
everything go all in and obsess over
making the greatest goddamn videos every
single day of their life like they're
really hard to find and be able to
sacrifice everything for that video yeah
like basically you put all the money
right back in yeah or the people doing
it they're on just a small scale and if
I talk to them it's just 99.9 of the
time I'm teaching them things and it's
like so it's lonely because there's not
too many people especially in the
creative space that are as crazy as you
yeah it is 100 it's it's so it's not
what I I was expecting I was expecting
there'd be a lot of people like me but
well I guess the guy would talk to Elon
Musk is a bit like you in that sense
yeah just in a different domain yeah
yeah exactly just willingness to put it
all back in right and that's why I found
right now a lot of the people I relate
to don't even make YouTube videos like
they're just like I'm viewing more and
more away from fellow content creators
and more to just you know I'm just
looking for those other people who just
share a little bit of it so I don't feel
so [ __ ] crazy all the time like you
know what I mean
um it's like people I feel normal around
and they tend to just be doing the
randomest things but you know loving it
well I think that's really inspiring
it's uh
let's take the Bukowski line and find
what you love and let it kill you is
really put everything
put everything into the thing you love
and that that's like the way to really
create special stuff but it's also the
way to yeah
you have to be careful given this advice
because
they're like they're like bodybuilders
who'll be like just go to the gym be
disciplined I'm disciplined go to gym
but I would argue for those people it's
like it's not even discipline they just
enjoy weightlifting right if you because
there are people who are jacked but they
don't make much money or run a business
right if they're that disciplined they
would they would be hitting every area
of their life they just really like
business and there's people like me who
just to an extreme level love building
companies right it's not even
disciplined for me it's just in my blood
it's what I wake up I don't think about
it I don't push myself I don't need to
watch a [ __ ] motivational video to go
work I just do it it's programmed in me
at this point and I couldn't imagine a
world where I don't wake up and do it
every day
um but I think that a little bit of it
is genetics
um and just how you're hardwired uh not
that it can't be trained or taught and
not that you know and obviously the
friend group you're in influences these
things and over time I think can change
it but someone's just not gonna be able
to flip a switch and then just start
doing a kamikaze approach to building a
business just like a lot of people try
to flip a switch and start bodybuilding
and quit majority of the time you know
that's uh just not innate to him but I
think a lot of us have the capacity to
do that in some domain yeah I think if
you went about strategically if you
surrounded yourself with fellow
like-minded people and you know slowly
over time switched it uh but if you just
try to like hardcore do it you're just
going to lose your mind
do you ever worry about your mental
health did you take step to protect it
to uh
yeah to like for the long run to make
sure you have the mental strength to go
on yes weirdly enough the best thing for
my mental health was giving in to my
innate nature to work and the most
depressed I get is when I try to
restrict it and like I don't work
weekends so I don't work this day what's
best for me is just to work when I feel
like working and then
just not work when I don't like and just
have no constraints because there are
just some nights where I don't want to
sleep and for whatever reason I feel
compelled to go all night whatever like
just do it you know do whatever you want
it's what I tell my like working brain
um and I just give in to it and I feel
that's where I feel the happiest and and
then um you know it's typically like
when I'm really in The Grind Mode it'll
be like seven or eight days and just
non-stop going going and then it's like
oh I'll realize like oh I need some
recharge time and then go [ __ ] binge
a season of anime yeah but listen here
but that's the thing like people will
tell you don't work weekends or don't do
this or don't work past this or blah
blah give you all these constraints but
for me and it's unconventional I just
give into it I think there's something
really to be said for that I I try to
surround myself with people that like
what I don't when I pull an all-nighter
they don't go like you should get more
sleep there's a reason I pulled that
all-nighter like if I'm really
passionate about something they say they
basically encourage it because I I have
no problem getting sleep and getting
rest
um what I need in my life is people that
encourage you to kind of keep going keep
going with the thoughts that you're
passionate about normal people They
don't want that life and they probably
shouldn't it's not good for you
um but yeah is if you hang around people
like just whatever different people
you're gonna feel crazy and it's gonna
wear on you whereas if you're around
similar people it just it's so much
easier like if you
you know
um I've started weightlifting more and
like one thing that's helped is just
having Jack people around me because
they naturally just eat healthier they
do like they naturally just have
freaking grilled chicken and all this
[ __ ] and high protein meals and it's
just like easier for me to just
piggyback and be like oh can you just
order me whatever you're getting uh and
they're like I gotta go to the gym and
I'll be like oh [ __ ] I'll just join you
you know and it's like it's just it's
cheat codes you know I mean just
surround yourself with people that you
want to be and it makes it like 70
easier in my opinion it's like that is
the cheat code to life
um and I wish I obviously your audience
is definitely a lot older but you know
to the older people listening like if
you have are in a place of mentorship
for someone younger or have influence
over younger people you should really
try to drill that in their heads like
the people are there around 100 dictates
the outcome I would not be on 120
million subscribers if I didn't find uh
when I was around a million I had a
couple friends that were just also
Psychopaths you know I outgrew them but
at the time it was great and I wouldn't
be where I am today if it wasn't for
them
um and just all along the way the
friends that I hung out with had such a
dramatic impact on wearing them like I'd
probably have 80 million less
subscribers you know if it was if I
wasn't so strategic about hanging out
with people that I add value to and they
also add value to me so the advice for
young people would be to
be very selective about the people you
saw yourself so selective it's it's
crazy like Chris you know he's I I he's
really funny and that's why he's great
for the videos and part of why he's so
funny is he consumes copious amounts of
cartoons and just funny content and so
I'll find like when I spend more time
with Chris I'll start just quoting these
weird cartoons and shows and like my
speech will literally change and just
after like a week of spending more time
with him it has like it's like that
quick out of effect you know now picture
that over the course of years I mean
yeah it has such a huge influence like
pluck one of their friends out and
hypothetically put me in there and yeah
you know there's no doubt if they're
trying to become a content creator there
are odds of success is 10x right
obviously you can't do that but you got
to find your closest version of it and
just be selective yeah but this also
applies not just the younger to older
people to agree but they it's it's even
more I like when I was a teenager I just
you know I couldn't relate to many
people I just I was like a [ __ ]
freaking nature because no one was
obsessed with building businesses or any
of this kind of stuff and so like back
then you know that advice would have
been helpful maybe not that particular
but just knowing that there are you know
it's not that you're a freaking nature
you just haven't found people that have
the same interests so the task is not to
feel sorry for yourself or somehow
change yourself it's more to finally
find people you fit in with yeah yeah
assuming which you know you're not
getting comproment uh like I assume it's
not something bad right like if your
hobby is shooting things you know or
shooting things you shouldn't be
shooting you know don't find people that
encourage that but
outside of that for sure uh actually as
an answer to what is the best advice
someone ever gave you you said you're
crazy until you're successful then
you're a genius 100 all along the way
people gave me so much
you know advice on why I shouldn't be
doing it why I'm crazy every step of the
way people wanted to tell me why I
shouldn't be doing this and should get
alive should stop being too obsessed
everything everything under the book
um and then once I'm successful those
same people are like dank
you're a genius wow you really you
pulled that off those are probably the
same people that will give you advice
now you're the most successful video
creator of all time stick to that
anytime you want to do something new
right yeah uh they'll they'll like
pressure you not to do the um
you know feastables or or mobile gaming
or whatever lays Beyond yeah it's funny
how people don't well honestly they're
the type of people I just don't talk to
anymore
I don't even know what they have to say
now so most people on the team are like
yes and they're like whatever the idea
you got they they're with it no it's
weird we actually have a my team pushes
back on me pretty hardcore which I want
I don't want Yes Man and yeah they're
they're like uh they're James you know
the CEO who helped me build all this um
he's very adamant like we're not yes men
and and he trains people to really think
for themselves and even when I give them
orders like really think like is this
optimal is there context or information
Jimmy could be missing that I can
provide that could help him make a more
updated decision like I'm not
um God you know what I mean like I'm
human and I make errors and so don't
take what I say that's the Bible
so even like in the brainstorming and so
on they can they can push back yeah you
can see it like Tyler anytime I said
something he would give me feedback and
push back which is what I want I don't
want him just to be like yes you're
[ __ ] genius good job Jimmy you know I
don't need that you know I need negative